[Music]
Canela on your run away we're filming to
start with me I have something important
to tell you I came to tell you big over
I have something important to tell you I
am something to tell you no one else ok
dad you know it takes what because you
could render it yes yeah you're pretty
but still give you [ __ ] now man no no
take your butt out take your butt up in
the air
now put your head lower than your butt
you're honest yeah yeah that's it bird
sir
ok
[Music]
idiot wait you know service guys I kind
of like split my hair when I turn and
she just got startled by it so she fell
off and my mom tried to save her my
uncle trying to save her and everybody's
trying to save each other but they're
all just like falling off the cliff
slowly like boom boom boom boom boom
and I'm just saying they're watching I'm
like there goes my whole family off the
[ __ ] cliff anyway you're not 16
I am 16 no you're not I stand when I am
excuse me you know happy birthday right
my birthday is coming up this year - are
you guys can come bring your cousin's -
my birthday I want them no guarantee my
birthday
she's showing you much I don't care 26
it says I don't know why you just do
that at me what my stepdad would have
done she didn't die yeah I know
[Music]